ja wieder verschoben exit wirft auch im
sicherheitsbereich viele fragen auf es
geht vor allem darum welche auswirkungen
der austritt großbritanniens auch die
sicherheit europas die
handlungsfähigkeit der eu als
internationaler krisen manager und auf
europäische verteidigung setzen haben
kann heute in vechta kompakt
sicherheitspolitische folgendes praxis
[Musik]
die heftigen diskussionen im zuge des
austritts für fans drehen sich vorrangig
um wirtschaftliche belange sicherheits
und verteidigungspolitische aspekte
blieben bislang im hintergrund
vermutlich auch deshalb weil dieser
bereich keine vergemeinschaftung der
materie darstellt bei der premiere
brüssel oder sagen hat die gemeinsame
sicherheits und verteidigungspolitik der
eu kurz gsvp ist eine angelegenheit der
jeweiligen regierungen sie bestimmen wie
weit sie sich einbringen und bereit sind
im eu-rahmen aktiv mitzuwirken
eine trennung gestaltet sich daher
wesentlich einfacher als beispielsweise
im handelsbereich politisch strategisch
betrachtet bedeutet der austritt eine
schwächung der eu im globalen wettbewerb
großbritannien ist vetomacht im
sicherheitsrat der vereinten nationen un
atommacht es verfügt über besondere
marine kapazitäten und hat mehr als zehn
militärische übersee standorte es weist
eine geostrategische denkt kultur auf
die manchmal die eu internen debatten
hilfreich war enge und nationale
ansichten zu überwinden
allerdings ist anzumerken dass das
vereinigte königreich seine besonderen
kapazitäten der eu kaum zur verfügung
gestellt oder in deren namen eingesetzt
hat großbritannien war von anfang an
kein anhänger einer selbständigen
europäischen sicherheits und
verteidigungspolitik
es vertrat immer die position der usa
sei daher die nato als
verteidigungsbündnis und die eu als
krisen und katastrophen manager in
ergänzung zur nato dementsprechend hat
london zb ein eigenes hauptquartier für
eu einsätze abgelehnt weniger als drei
prozent des personals für militärische
operationen gestellt sowie eine
budget erhöhung für die europäische
verteidigungsagentur abgelehnt
großbritannien beteiligt sich auch nicht
an der ständigen strukturierten
zusammenarbeit
es hat sich im laufe der zeit den ruf
eines blockierers eingehandelt ein
besonderes feld stellt der
rüstungssektor da die eu ist seit jahren
bestrebt den europäischen rüstungs
bedarf samt produktion zu koordinieren
und damit auch kosten zu sparen
großbritannien ist der größte
rüstungsproduktion westeuropas und sitz
von sieben der 100 weltweit größten
rüstungsunternehmen
bisher hat es jährlich circa 16 prozent
des budgets der europäischen
verteidigungsagentur getragen 2016 waren
das viereinhalb millionen euro und hat
vom verteidigungs forschungsprogramm der
eu mitgewirkt das wird man keinem
austritt nicht mehr möglich sein vom
satellitennavigationssystem galileo zu
dessen entwicklung london über 1,3
milliarden euro beigesteuert hat wurde
großbritannien 2018 bereits
ausgeschlossen
der zweite standort der galileo
sicherheits überwachungszentrale wurde
von großbritannien nach spanien
verlagert was tut sich was zeichnet sich
ab im operativen bereich ist der wandel
bereits in gange so wurde das
hauptquartier für eu einsätze von
northwood nach frankreich und spanien
verlegt die teilnahme londons an den
sogenannten battle groups den krisen
einsatzkräften der eu wurde infolge der
planungsunsicherheit schon eingestellt
andere eu staaten werden in der zweiten
jahreshälfte 2009 10 die lücke füllen
ebenso kann der stellvertretende nato
kommandeur in europa in der regel ein
drittel setzte die von der nato
unterstützt werden nicht mehr
kommentieren
schwierig wird es sein die britischen
marine kapazitäten zu ersetzen
im nachrichtendienstlichen und
rüstungsbereich hängt die kooperation
von den jeweiligen befindlichkeiten und
nationalen interessen ab möglichkeiten
für eine intensive zusammenarbeit sind
gegeben
allerdings wird london nicht mehr die
serien zugangs und einflussmöglichkeiten
sowie rechte haben wie als vollmitglied
im politisch strategischen bereich ist
zu erwarten dass politische blockaden
wegfallen
die entscheidungen rascher getroffen
werden können das eher psychologische
manko des austritts könnte durch ein
ambitioniertes auftreten und die
verstärkte zusammenarbeit der eu-27
kompensiert werden
fraglich ist aber er zukünftig den
geopolitischen weitblick des vereinigten
königreichs einbringen kann
bisher haben vertreter beider seiten
betont die kooperation im
sicherheitsbereich fortsetzen zu wollen
nach dem motto die sicherheit
großbritanniens und der eu sind
untrennbar verbunden
sicherheits und verteidigungspolitische
zusammenarbeit kann allerdings auch
außerhalb der eu und nato erfolgen ist
europa daher nach einem break sieht
weniger sicher oder die eu in ihren
möglichkeiten maßgeblich eingeschränkt
da großbritannien als starkes
nato-mitglied verbleibt ist militärisch
gesehen keine signifikante
beeinträchtigung der
verteidigungsfähigkeit europas zu
erwarten
auch die möglichkeiten der eu als
krisenmanager zu agieren werden durch
den breaks sind nicht wesentlich
geschmälert
von größerer bedeutung ist ob der
austritt großbritanniens eine stärkere
dynamik in richtung gemeinsame eu
verteidigung bewirken wird
eines kann aber festgehalten werden der
praxis wird die sicherheits und
verteidigungspolitische entwicklung der
eu viel weniger beeinflussen als der
handlungs wille der verbleibenden 27 eu
mitglieder